are you excited for some of the games
coming to nintendo switch well we've
learned exactly when arms and splatoon
two are headed to nintendo's new console
I'm Matt and this gamespot news update
is all about the switches most
anticipated games first up the bizarre
fighting game arms launches on june
sixteenth alongside the new neon yellow
joy con then we've got splatoon to
releasing this summer with three new
emil variations on inkling boy inkling
girl and squid players will also be able
to fight their way through the ink
shooters new horde mode which has the
excellent title of salmon run in the new
mode players will fight against enemy
salmon creatures as they come out of the
ocean defeating them allows you to
collect salmon eggs which basically work
as points and after you've done enough
splatting a boss will appear giving you
the opportunity to defeat it and collect
even bigger eggs splatoon two launches
for the switch on July 21st and in
related news nintendo is holding a
tournament for the first game on wii u
with the grand prize being a trip to III
the qualifying matches on april twenty
second while the grand final is on the
29th you can go to battle 5.com /
splatoon for full rules and registration
but if you want some ink splat and color
role in action right now check out our
archive live stream of splatoon tues
global test fire